and if you do not believe me look at
this comment I got where I said every
single thing and this person got it this
was for the Microsoft leap
apprenticeship they got the
apprenticeship after doing these things
hello everybody my name is Nia and I'm
the black female engineer I provide
content for you and aspiring software
engineers and today we are going to talk
about everything you need to get in
order to actually have a shot at the
amazing apprenticeship programs coming
up this year apprenticeship programs are
one of the best ways to get your foot in
the door and not only just foot but like
your whole body in the door because a
lot of the time after you get the
apprenticeship program you are basically
on track to being a full-time employee
really great apprenti programs include
Pinterest Airbnb which is actually open
now Google Microsoft LinkedIn Shopify
there's so many and I just see so many
people not even getting a shot because
they don't know how to actually put
their best foot forward so not anymore
we're going to fix that right now I've
added open and upcoming apprenticeships
in the description box below so make
sure you check those out when it comes
to putting your best foot forward for
these programs we're going to focus on
three main things your resume your
GitHub and your LinkedIn I highly
encourage you to optimize these three
things and to not really consider
yourself done or set up well to be
honest if you haven't done this so let's
start with your resume now with these
programs the understanding typically is
that the applicant does not have any
previous Tech experience and that is the
want they want people who are not
developers who do not have a computer
science degree already they want people
transitioning into this field so do not
stress about oh my goodness I don't have
any relevant experience to put what you
do need to do is focus on these two main
parts your professional experience in
general and your projects starting with
your professional experience we need to
show that we are a fantastic candidate
based on the transferable skills we
bring from our previous experience what
are transferable skills transferable
skills are skills that we acquired from
a different industry from a different
field but are extremely relevant and
important to the ultimate job we want a
job in Tech a job as a software engineer
as a data engineer Etc top transferable
skills for Tech include being detail
oriented high levels of communication
skills being able to see a problem and
enact tangible real solutions to solve
that that problem and so think back to
your previous experience and say okay in
what ways did I exhibit skills that this
job calls for before becoming a software
engineer I had jobs in accounting and
finance and so what I had put in my
resume was investigate leading causes of
profit or loss in the stock market that
day based on these three factors I
definitely sprued it up but do we see
how that one line sh know like oh okay
so she she can look at data and come to
a conclusion so what I suggest doing is
looking up top transferable skills for
Blink the job that you want and see that
list and see okay how can I use my
previous experience as proof of me
acquiring and using those skills another
thing you're going to want to do in the
professional experience part of your
resume is list off off within the first
eight words some type of metric the
format you want to follow is the impact
you had by way of some Metric and then
how you did that thing something I could
say for my finance job is reduced data
processing time by
20% by utilizing python to analyze these
three main points of of data I don't
even think I used python I think I used
starts with the V the thing I used to
speed up the whole data process we want
to hit them immediately with the impact
we had and then how we did it don't just
simply say what your job was because
like we can just get that from the job
description don't tell me what you did
please tell me the impact you had so
that's the professional section of our
resume now we have the project section
within your project section you're going
to put two
projects and list them off pretty
similarly to how you would list off a
job I'm going to add in an example for
you to follow along with list off the
project name the tech you used and then
two to three bullet points on the
problem that project solves and key
metrics again like our professional
experience a project I had when I was
first learning to code was basically Al
in all recipes you know a person could
go and search the recipe they want let's
say for lamb and then all of these
different recipes would come up and I
would provide a shopping list for them
and all of this and so if I listed that
within my resume I would have the
project name which was mins the
technology I used which was Vanilla
JavaScript and Ruby on Rails and then
two to three bullet points starting off
with enhanced users Meal Time prep by
providing thousands of dinner options
based on their preferences and then
follow that up with metrics so a metric
I had was something like queried 5,000
plus recipes from the I think it was
called Edom from the Edom or edamame API
in order to provide users with a wide
array of recipes and just many options
so say the problem you're SOL in and
then provide metrics provide data
provide anything that is a number to
show okay we did this and I did that and
I pulled from here because will truly
add so much more impact with what you're
saying it'll also provide proof to the
person looking at your resume that okay
she actually did something here she's
not just making something up she's being
specific I can trust in what she is
claiming she did check the description
box all also for some resum templates
and examples now let's talk about our
GitHub our GitHub is the
portfolio for our coding experience
you're not required to have a ton you're
not required to have built some AI super
computer or anything but you typically
are required or I guess not required
because do what you want but the people
who are going to receive call backs are
the people who truly show an interest in
this new career and how do you show an
interest by building projects so this is
how we set up our GitHub to act like a
really fantastic project for our
applications and that way we also don't
have to mess around with creating a
whole portfolio website or anything like
that because secret I have never had a
portfolio website I find them personally
to be a waste of time when GitHub is
right there so what you're going to do
first first off is make sure the
projects you want to showcase pick
between two and five aim for three make
sure those projects have a thorough
readme and a thorough read me is a
readme with the following section an
intro section sharing what the project
is what it's about what challenges it
solves Technologies use a walkthrough
video code Snippets challenges faced key
features in what is next for your app
even if you never want to touch it again
what would be the logical next step for
it then also at the very bottom just add
in ways to contact you ideally your
LinkedIn URL now let me talk about the
walkthrough video very quickly this is
very important because a lot of times
the person reviewing your application
isn't extremely technical it is a
recruiter or typical regular recruiter
for the job and so they may not be able
to re read the code Snippets but they
can look at a video and see what your
code turned into and so what you want to
do is simply create a screen recording
of you using your project whether it's a
web app a mobile app a game whatever it
it may be create a screen recording and
then upload that screen recording to
YouTube but don't worry no one you don't
want to see it will see it because
you're going to publish it under
unlisted unlisted simply means that the
only people who can see this video see
that this video even exists are people
who have the URL so you're going to mark
it as unlisted and take that URL and add
it into your GitHub you don't have to
show your face you don't have to talk at
all just use the app the way a user
would use the app and also make sure
you're including key features that you
would want want to present now what you
want to do is Mark those two to five
projects that you have with the thorough
readmes make sure you mark those in your
GitHub profile as featured projects this
makes it so that once a person lands on
your profile they see your projects
front and center they don't have to go
digging for anything it's very clear and
that's what they will gravitate towards
now we have our readme put together we
have the project we've selected we need
to make our GitHub profile read as a
portfolio and as an additional look into
who we are as a developer this is the
platform I love for very quickly and
easily making your GitHub from something
that's just super Bland and kind of just
like nothing to something very very
informative and quite impressive now on
your profile you'll have the
Technologies you're proficient in your
key projects intros about you it's so
much more informative and also informs
the companies you're applying to like oh
no I'm serious like no me here oh oh you
have a serious person on your hands and
a very interested person at your hands
so beep beep like call me back so
amazing our GitHub
looks now let's talk about our LinkedIn
our resume expresses our experience our
GitHub expresses our portfolio our
projects our LinkedIn expresses how we
show up professionally so we need to
make sure that headshot is updated it is
crisp it is clear every single head shot
I've ever had on my LinkedIn has been
from a selfie the one I have right now I
was in my bedroom I was against the wall
and I went click and that was all that
is all it took I went into canva added a
pretty little ring around my frame and
now that is my LinkedIn profile and I a
pretty good one if you ask me next your
headline take out the word aspiring from
your headline right now I don't want to
see a SP in nothing on your headline it
needs to say software engineer data
engineer cyber security analyst whatever
again the roles you're applying for are
it needs to say that you are that would
you hire an aspiring Chef an aspiring
doctor right so please remove the word
aspiring or training or whatever from
your headline and claim what you are a
software engineer because that's what's
great about tech is we don't need to
have a job to be that thing just like
how with a chef you don't need to be
actively working to claim that you are a
chef because that is what you are in
your heart and soul so show people that
I am a software engineer I'm a developer
that that's all there is no questions
ifs ands or butts about it in your about
section add in just some info about
yourself what industry were you in
before and what motivated you to pursue
this new career it doesn't have to be
anything crazy 3 to six sentences have
chat PT help you and we're all good now
go down to your experience section and
make sure it perfectly matches your
resume when I say perfectly matches I
mean it has the exact same titles that
you put in your resume it has the exact
same bullet points you put in your
resume even for your project don't think
oh it's the project I don't need bullet
points yes you
do yes you do yep so go in in your
resume the resume Wiis proed up and made
beautiful and amazing and crisp and
clean copy it and add it straight onto
your LinkedIn and now boom we have your
professional experience and projects
which for me I had put projects under
professional experience because what
about it like you're not going to tell
me that this isn't technically
professional experience so I put my
project in my professional experience
and listed the bullet points off just
like I had done and boom I had a
beautifully laid out Link in and then
make sure under your skills you list all
the different skills and Tech your
profession in JavaScript Ruby iOS HTML
CSS all of it bootstrap all of it and
once we have those three things we are
set up for a very successful application
process and just apprenticeship season
and if you do not believe me look at
this comment I got where I said every
single thing I said there but honestly I
was even less detailed because you know
it's short form so what are you going to
do we're on YouTube so we have a little
bit more time together and this person
got it this was for the Microsoft leap
apprenticeship they got the
apprenticeship after doing these things
okay y'all so please save yourself the
headache and make me very very happy
please by doing these things before we
start applying as I mentioned airbnb's
applications for their apprenti ship
program is already out however there are
a couple more days left I want to say
their applications closed on Monday so
we got to get on our Zoom do all the
things and we'll be chilling check out
the resource in the description box
below what else do you want to know what
else do you need help with and let's
let's get you there thank you so much
for watching y'all I will talk to y'all
super soon and Happy Valentine's weekend
I hope y'all feel the love I love y'all
and I really appreciate you being here
so I'll talk to you later bye